what up space fam golson here from anime
outbroad back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one piece story oda has shocked a lot of
people with this chapter we find out
whether or not yamato will be the final
member of the straw hat crew wanna
officially wraps up in a big way and
more so make sure to stay tuned for this
one if you do enjoy seeing these
one-piece reviews and want to keep them
coming channel parking within and smash
that like button with no mercy be a
smashing pirate king rather than a
passing orochi and youtube will reward
you with wano fireworks celebrating this
long arc's conclusion make this the
video subscribe if you haven't already
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications so you don't miss
future one-piece reviews and updates now
let's jump into the chapter spoilers and
all so this one is called final curtain
which completes the whole act 1 act 2
and so on structure we've had in mono
thus far it feels like we've been
wrapping up juana for a while now but to
be fair it was a long arc a very long
arc it makes sense that it would take
some time to wrap it up in a satisfying
way through all the time we spent on it
and with people like momo and kinemon
i'm sure a bunch of us would feel
cheated if it went by too quick the
chapter starts with the new legendary
history being told about how the royal
retainers aka the red scabbards went
through many hardships as the evening of
the fire festival starts to unfold for
centuries to come they'll be telling the
story of how kaido was overcome and
although many feel like the scabbards
didn't do that much in the war
comparatively speaking it's nice to see
that their bravery was rewarded here in
wanos history as kiriman momo and yamato
heading to the straw hat ship yamato
drops the huge bombshell and we'll get
right into that but first now to thank
today's sponsor space sleeper cocoon a
perfect intergalactic quest across time
and space awaits you in this rpg gotcha
mobile game with many unique and very
cute characters to collect and battle
with and it's available for ios and
android devices link in the description
from wolf waifus to cute pepper girls
yes that's right this game is creative
enough to have a leaper based on red
peppers and she's adorable by the way
space sleeper is filled with such
amazing diverse character designs which
are coupled with unique and engaging
personality in fact space sleeper
partnered with vtuber doranana who is
based on space sleeper's protagonist
doranana not only looks super cute but
appreciates the greatness of coffee as i
learned in her q a video which means a
lot to a caffeine dependent light form
like myself the game boasts formidable
rogue-like gameplay and i love to see
the cute characters using their cool and
unique moves to defeat the opposing
forces in space sleeper cocoon cosmic
radiation caused transformations of the
creatures and objects and now you can
enjoy all of these cute characters in
pixel perfect 2d yes this game looks
great all around for me it's always fun
seeing the creative designs and guessing
what animal or object was transformed to
create each whether it's the lion based
leonlev the cat based doranana or the
wolf-based amber you got a ton to choose
from when building your own cute but
deadly squad the mobile experience is
also available on every screen allowing
you to see your to quote
pretties on whatever device you have at
hand so what are you waiting for support
the channel by downloading slc and
assembling your own squad right now use
the code leap2u for 10 free draws so
back to yamato as i was saying she drops
a bombshell a big one kinamon and momo
say what in surprise asking if she's
really not heading out to see and yamato
answers nope she's staying she's even
already spoken to luffy and the others
about it kinamon and momo make it clear
that she's welcome to stay but they're
just confused after all a moment ago she
said she'd made up her mind that she was
going and the reason is funny you may
think she's finally decided to choose
her own way rather than to follow odin's
example but no it's just the opposite in
fact she says odin started his journey
with a tour of wano so she's going to do
that because that would be more odin
right now than going off to see so
that's a pretty hilarious reason not to
go however she adds she's sure that
she'll find her way if she follows in
odin's footsteps and she's bound to make
it to c sooner or later which to me is
probably referring to the final big war
where luffy will need everyone he met
along the way to assist him momo for his
part is hilariously shocked that she had
the time to explain all this while luffy
and the straw hats didn't even say bye
to him so let's talk about this
practically everyone was saying that
yamato already joined the straw hats or
was joining the straw hats and was going
to be luffy's final 10th crewmate and
that by the way that 10 number is not
counting luffy himself and some people
even thought that the last chapter
confirmed she would be joining but the
whole time i've been saying if you look
at all the past trapped reviews i've
been saying i won't believe it until she
set sail with them and wanna was no
longer in sight and here i'm personally
not surprised to see that yamato has not
joined although it would have been
pretty cool if she did i get why some
people would be surprised though because
oda was purposely teasing the idea
pretty hard right up to the last chapter
luffy wanted yamato yamato said she's in
the crew and then in the last chapter
she said she's going to the straw hats
but as i said before yamato has the
guardian deity of wano fruit where does
that belong in wano protecting wano
furthermore her friendship with momo was
consistently emphasized and built up
foreshadowing that they would continue
to be there for one another as guardians
of wano plus wano needs all the
firepower it can get right now and
yamato is a strong force that could even
hold back kaido albeit temporarily so it
makes sense that she'd stay lastly when
it was revealed that we already have a
mythical zone on the crew namely luffy
it took some of the luster from straw
hat candidate yamato since we were no
longer missing a rare mythical zone
member to have on the crew so i don't
actually think people should be too
surprised by this even if oda did try
pretty hard to trick everyone into
thinking that yamato would be the final
crew member but let me know your
thoughts on this are you happy or sad do
you get why yamato didn't become a straw
hat or is it an upsetting twist for you
so back to momo being mad because he
feels disrespected by luffy since his
friend didn't bid him a proper farewell
he recalls all their history and how
luffy brought out the best in him helped
him to become a man pretty much he
remembers how luffy made it possible for
them to do the impossible to beat kaido
and to save the people of wana momo
continues to get himself more and more
angry as he rushes towards luffy he says
luffy is mistaking being free which is
luffy's main thing with being free to be
rude i love this little clash here
between luffy's ideology and the proper
etiquette associated with samurai
culture momo even looks to kinemon to
fire him up even more as kinemon says
he's not wrong kinemon even says he may
have no choice but to cleave luffy apart
depending on his words and momo agrees
with only yamato being like yeah you
guys are blowing this out of proportion
now we jump to kidlaw and luffy lost his
stuff that's just become a thing pirates
say to each other he says remember the
next time we meet it'll be as enemies
don't whine to me if we're shooting to
kill and luffy says gotcha it's like
what shanks and buggy said to each other
when they were apprentice pirates but
when they finally met up they were still
friends i'm sure it'll be the same for
luffy and law finally momo and yamato
arrived momo bearing fangs while yamato
is smiling and waving saying they've
come to see them off momo tackles luffy
still angry but he quickly goes from a
scary intimidating face to bawling his
eyes out saying please don't leave i'll
be lonely it's a hilarious twist that
isn't hard to predict when you remember
how young momo actually is on the inside
all his anger up to this point was
really just covering up his sadness momo
says he was able to survive because of
luffy he can laugh again and avenge his
mother and father because of luffy even
a smiling zorro calls it a pitiful sight
but everyone is okay with it because
nami says he's still a little kid luffy
explains that they are still here
because they were waiting to give momo
this he gives him a straw hat pirate
flag and calls momo his little brother
so it's mirroring how odin was a little
brother to whitebeard and arguably to
roger as well luffy says the flag will
let people know that messing with their
friends is the same as messing with the
straw hats it's so hype and cool that
luffy has put wano under his protection
and it's exactly what needed to happen
to make me believe that wanna will
actually be okay without him here with
this and yamato staying i feel like wano
is in a solid position and i think oda
did that well when momo asks if he's one
of them luffy says that if any one of
them wants to be a pirate he'll comfort
them right away he just says he won't
have weak links on board which is
classic luffy and then momo starts
acting tougher right away yamato is told
to take care of them and the straw hat
set sail as momo the shogun bows down to
the ground as far as he can go to show
his deep respect and gratitude to luffy
and the others momo promises to kinemon
that he will surpass odin and kinemon
agrees saying he'll be by his side when
that happens we get a hilarious comic
relief moment of yamato saying are you
talking about me and they both scream
out no
so it's good to see that we're still
going to get yamato being odin slash not
being odin jokes we get another great
moment between these three captains
before they part ways the smart way to
leave wano is to use the lift that
lowers ships but since kidd says only
wusses do that luffy and law decide
they'll all take the dangerous route of
just rushing down i will definitely miss
this dynamic i gotta say the narrator
calls these three the real life wisdom
kings and says their power descended
like a wrathful tsunami obliterating all
its path even kaido the dragon king and
the yokai possessed giant oyrun failed
to withstand their assault the heavens
themselves were torn as painful shrieks
verbatid through the air so that's how
our pirate boys will be remembered in
mono history as powerful wisdom kings
which is pretty cool we then go back to
the performance where hiori and orochi
are being talked about we hear how
orochi was thwarted by denjiro odin's
second disciple after orochio nigashima
and kaido fell the sun had finally
pierced the dark clouds that were
suffocating wano for 20 long years the
skies were clear hiyori is given a
special role in this performance no
longer having to bite her tongue as she
did in the last 20 years she says to
orochi the kurozumi which means charcoal
were born to burn mirroring odin's born
to boil quote the crowd goes crazy this
is some of that hollywood movie touch to
make the legend a bit more cinematic and
perfect then we fast forward to the day
after the festival and we're told the
violence saga has now become a joyous
reunion and we're told that is the
conclusion of today's tale on our
nation's renowned samurai we see a
picture of momo the scabbards and other
wano heroes smiling the curtain closes
on wano as momo is wondering where to
put luffy's flag and we're told
inherited will never fades a
long-running theme in the one piece
story for now at least wano gets a break
after so much war and misery luffy and
friends have freed yet another place
successfully and now that one was done
people can finally rate it as a
standalone arc so let me know what would
you give it out of 10 and is it your
favorite arc if not which ones do you
prefer yes one was long very long but it
also had some of the most hyped one
piece moments ever so i'm not
complaining chill the parking within and
smash that like button with no mercy if
you enjoyed this video be a smashing
pirate king rather than a passing orochi
and youtube will reward you with wano
fireworks celebrating this long arc's
conclusion make this the video subscribe
if you haven't already and hit that
notification bell turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece reviews and updates and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist that includes videos on
all the admirals mythical zones yonko
and much more link to that is in the
description and on screen right now and
until next time see ya space cowboys